COLLUSION, POSSIBLE COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA.
>> IT IS RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHTER]
SARAH SANDERS SPENT TWO YEARS AS
THE PRESS SECRETARY OVER THE
WHITE HOUSE.
EVERY DAY, SHE HAD TO TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
NICE TO SEE YOU BACK IN
WASHINGTON.
>> IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK.
EVERY DAY, DO YOU REMEMBER THE
NAME OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT, THE DUMB GUY?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY.
>> Tucker: NO, JIM ACOSTA.
EVERYDAY YOU HAD TO SIT THERE.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT POLICIES
WHICH IS TOTALLY LEGITIMATE, YOU
ARE ALLOWED, BUT THE IMPLICATION
HE WAS WORKING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> I MEAN, SO MANY TIMES THEY
WERE SO OUT OF CONTROL AND
ABSURD IN THE ACCUSATIONS THEY
WERE MAKING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE LITERALLY ACCUSING HIM
OF BEING A TRAITOR TO HIS OWN
COUNTRY.
IT WAS MIND-BOGGLING AT TIMES TO
LISTEN TO THE REPEATED
OUTRAGEOUS ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
BUT THE GOOD THING WAS, WE GOT
TO THE TRUTH.
FINALLY, I THINK WE ARE SEEING
ALL OF THAT COME OUT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS AND MONTHS.
I THINK WHAT WE SAW THIS WEEK
WAS FURTHER INDICATION THAT THIS
WHOLE THING HAS BEEN A COMPLETE
AND UTTER SHAM FROM THE
BEGINNING.
>> Tucker: WHAT I FIND SO
FASCINATING, ALMOST MESMERIZING
ABOUT THE STORY, IT WAS NEVER A
CLOSE CALL.
WE CAN DEBATE THE PRESIDENT'S
TRADE POLICY OR WHATEVER, ANY
OTHER POLICY, BUT THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER OR NOT HE COLLUDED
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN TO STEAL THE
ELECTIONS FROM HILLARY CLINTON
WAS SO CRAZY FROM DAY ONE THAT I
ALWAYS WONDERED, DO THEY REALLY
BELIEVE IT?
DO YOU THINK THE REPORTERS
REALLY BELIEVE IT?
>> I THINK SOME DID.
I THINK THEY CONVINCE THEMSELVES
IT WAS REAL BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
VALIDATE WHERE THEY HAD BEEN SO
LONG.
I THINK PART OF THE KIND OF
MEDIA CLASS WAS SO TAKEN BY
SURPRISE THAT DONALD TRUMP
BECAME PRESIDENT, THAT THEY HAD
NO OTHER EXPLANATION OTHER THAN
THERE MUST HAVE BEEN SOME SORT
OF SCANDAL AROUND IT.
AND THEY COULDN'T ADMIT THE FACT
THEY WERE COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
WRONG.
THE SAD THING IS, YOU WOULD
THINK THEY WOULD LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THAT OVER THE LAST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS, BUT THEY HAVEN'T.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE DOUBLING DOWN
AND GETTING IT WRONG AGAIN.
EVERY TIME THEY TRY TO NAIL THIS
PRESENT ON SOMETHING WITH THAT
THAT SHAM RUSSIA HOAX OR THE
SHAM OF UKRAINE SCANDAL, THEY
LOSE.
WHETHER IT WAS THE ECONOMY, THEY
SAID THE ECONOMY WOULD
COMPLETELY COLLAPSE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY BOOMING.
THEY SAID THE PRESIDENT COULDN'T
GET GOOD TRADE DEALS, COULDN'T
DEFEAT ISIS, THE MILITARY HE
COULDN'T REBUILD, NOT ONLY DID
HE DO IT BUT HE DOES IT BETTER
THAN EVEN I THINK SOME PEOPLE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION EXPECTED TO
HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: ONTO COLLUSION WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN, DID ANYONE EVER
APOLOGIZE TO YOU?
DID ANYONE OFF CAMERA OFF THE
RECORD SAY, YOU KNOW, IT IS
PRETTY CLEAR HE ACTUALLY WASN'T
WORKING FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> NO, NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT, BUT ANY OF
THE OTHER OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS THAT
THEY MADE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
OR HIS STAFF.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN AN
ADMINISTRATION ATTACK SO HEAVILY
AND SOMETIMES SO PERSONALLY.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE ATTACKED.
AND YOU WERE ATTACKED BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE JIM ACOSTA WERE
MAKING CLAIMS TOTALLY
UNSUPPORTED BY FACT, WILD
TREASON.
DOING IT IN THEM TAKE GOSH, I'M
SORRY WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR
FAMILY.
>> THERE WERE CERTAINLY MOMENTS
AFTER WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
OR OTHER MOMENTS WHERE
JOURNALISTS, EVEN THE VERY FAR
LEFT CAME AND SAID THEY WERE
SORRY FOR WHAT HAD HAPPENED.
BUT THEY DIDN'T TAKE AWAY FROM
THE FACT THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
PUSH COMPLETELY FALSE NARRATIVE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
FOR THAT, I DON'T NEED THE
APOLOGY, BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DO.
THEY HAVE WASTED SO MUCH TIME
AND SO MUCH ENERGY.
JUST THINK HOW MUCH MORE THE
PRESIDENT COULD HAVE GOTTEN DONE
HAD THEY NOT BEEN SLAMMING EVERY
SINGLE MOMENT THIS RUSH OF
SCANDAL DOWN AMERICA'S THROAT.
>> Tucker: AND IT WILL HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
I DON'T SEE HOW JEFF WILL KEEP
HIS JOB AT CNN.
HE SHOULD BE FIRED A LONG TIME
AGO HIM.
>> NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THAT BUT
HIS RATINGS.
>> Tucker: I AGREE COMPLETELY.
THE FACT THAT JEFF ZUCKER RUNS
CNN, THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNOR